Hope you're enjoying the conference so far.
I wish I could be there in person, but this
is the next best thing.
And I'm excited to talk about accessibility
and coats of arms.
So, if you're someone who likes to follow
along with slides while the talk is going,
I did Tweet them out so you can go and look
me up on Twitter if you want to access those.
The inspiration for this talk is basically
in software design and development, often
we deal with complex problems and lessons
that can feel kind of novel and new at first.
But a lot of times these are problems that
people have wrestled with in some capacity
for years or even centuries.
So, I thought it would be interesting to take
a look at design, specifically accessibility,
within the historical lens of coats of arms.
So, it give you an idea of where we're headed,
I'll hope by giving you some historical context
about coats of arms and what they're for and
where they come from.
For the meat of this talk, we'll look at the
lessons we can learn from the designs of coats
of arms and how to apply those in our work
in software.
A popular place you might have seen coats
of arms recently is in Game of Thrones.
If you're a fan, you might recognize some
of the symbols like the Stark's direwolf or
the Lannister lion.
These had special meanings to the houses and
were used to identify people who belonged
to one of those houses.
Accessibility is kind of a big word.
And especially in the last two to five years,
it's been kind of a buzzword.
This talk is not meant to be an introduction
to accessibility.
There are college courses and degrees and
certificates on that subject.
But just to kind of look at best practices
of accessibility within a different historical
lens.
And hopefully you'll learn some interesting
things and kind of gain a new perspective.
So, as you probably know, accessibility's
about more than just what something looks
like.
So, more than just kind of using good contrast
and having a readable font.
It means designing for people with motor impairments,
by providing keyboard accessible functions
for everything that you expect a use to do.
Means accommodating screenreaders for your
website.
Things like that.
So, again, this is not intended to be a comprehensive
introduction to accessibility.
But I did pull the top ten rules on accessibility
practices from the guide to the Internet for
the EU.
And those are you don't worry about memorizing
these or anything.
I just to want review them quickly.
Number one, structured contents.
Avoid dependence on any one single sense,
eyesight in particular.
Help your users avoid mistakes.
If they make a mistake, show them how to correct
it.
Avoid flashing.
Try to provide text descriptions where possible.
Make the functions on your site or app keyboard
accessible.
Avoid rushing your users.
Identify links and where they will take you.
Keep navigation UI consistent and try and
keep your experience compatible across devices
and browsers.
So, I boiled those down more into three big
rules which are: Structure contents, avoid
dependence on any single sense and avoid rushing
your users or pigeonholing them into any one
action.
So, if you hear the term "Coats of arms,"
you might picture something like this.
That's not what it is.
The term is if I were getting ready for battle
and putting on a suit of armor, I would put
on a coat over that that would have a coat
of arms or essentially a crest printed on
it.
The purpose of a coat of arms is to be easily
identifiable for the house or country it represents.
And there are several reasons why that's good.
It enables you to record and embellish the
history of your nation in kind of a visual
format.
It was a way to identify the dead.
So that you could look at their coat and see
what house they belonged to.
A way to declare military units.
If I was traveling and saw a group of people,
I could see if they were friendly based on
what they were wearing.
A means to establish pedigree if you could
trace back your coat several generations and
a way to pass down family honors or symbols.
So, I'm gonna use the term "Heraldry."
Heraldry is the system by which coats of arms
and other bearings are devised, described
and regulated.
It's kind of the overarching context.
I'm going to use the terms emblem and seal
interchangeably with coats of arms.
They're considered subsets of coats of arms
if I show you something that's more like a
seal for a later, it's also a coat of arms.
I wanted to touch on rights of use for coats
of arms because I think it's kind of interesting.
I pulled facts from the countries I researched
while preparing for this talk.
In Denmark, any unlawful use of heraldic arms
is a criminal offense.
If I'm using a coat of arms that I don't have
the rights to, I could be charged criminally.
In Italy, heraldic matters were ruled outside
of the scope of official law.
Can in South Africa, they said all citizens
can wear arm it is they please.
So, kind of a more flexible approach there.
In Scotland, coats of arms are considered
inheritable property.
I inherit the family farm and then also the
family coat of arms.
And in Ireland, if you can trace back your
ancestry, you can be granted the rights to
a coat of arms.
So, I came up with a basic timeline for key
events in different regions surrounding this
concept.
So, the earliest reference that we have to
coats of arms in general is in 2000B.C., Egyptian
hieroglyphics and artwork, they had rulers
who wore emblems to signify why where they
came from.
And in the book of numbers in the Bible, it's
the insignia of the children of Italy, a precursor.
Then they were in use by western nobilities.
By the 16th century, strictly regulated in
Ireland.
And the 17th through 19th centuries, they
were widely used to record family history.
So, some interesting event there is.
Great.
Now let's see what we looked like.
I tried to pull a decedent sample size of
different kinds of designs.
It's not totally comprehensive.
And I'm going to start with what you are familiar
with you have seen crests in a tourist shop
or something like that.
They were probably from Scotland or Ireland.
So, often the ones that people are familiar
with are from Europe.
And particularly in this top row you can see
some design commonalities with the two figures
on either side and the shield in the forefront
and then some type of crown symbol and maybe
a motto as well.
You can see certain similarities in a lot
of those.
Asian heraldry, the ones for China and south
Korea look more like seals in this case.
They're kind of more round and bold.
The one representing the Russian empire, you
can see the western influence.
It's got kind of some similarities to the
ones on the previous slide.
And point out Japan in the bottom row, those
are pictures of Mon, emblems used to present
houses and we will talk about them.
And you can see western influence, particularly
with colonialism, with Nigeria, Malawi and
Somalia and Kenya, and you can see the supporters
on the central shield.
And then in the bottom right, the complete
of arms for Sudan has an eagle which is a
common trend for coats of arms from the Middle
East.
These are what some of the different heraldic
signs look like in the Middle East.
And you can see many feature this eagle which
is the eagle of Saladin and a motto on the
bottom.
It's interesting to see certain patterns in
various regions when it comes to their coats
of arms.
These are some of the symbols from the Americas.
These ones tend I think they all have some
kind of greenery which is kind of interesting.
They also tend to be a little bit taller than
the others which I also found to be interesting.
And maybe a little bit more color as well.
Great.
So, again, that's not obviously all of the
coats of arms there are, but it's a sampling.
So, we were to think about what makes a good
coat of arms, if we were to create our own,
we would want it to be easily identifiable.
Potentially across a battlefield to our enemies.
We might want to incorporate symbols that
have special meaning to us or look impressive
to someone else.
Those are things to keep in mind as we keep
going.
This is, again, some of the samples that I
showed you.
And you can see there's a lot of variety.
Some of them are extremely interesting, this
one from Haiti with minute details.
And some are more bold like this one from
China which is an emblem that pops out at
you from among the rest.
So, let's talk about some of the things that
are done well in a lens of modern standards
of accessibility.
And, again, there's no right and wrong because
these are works of art.
We're just choosing to look at them within
this particular framework.
So, generally these are pretty easily distinguishable.
So, these are some heraldic symbols from Germany.
And there are some similarities like the use
of the crown or the lion in some of them.
But if two of them were side by side, I probably
would be able to tell them apart pretty easily.
Which is good.
There's generally good color contrast.
This example is from Egypt.
And it's got an object in the forefront against
a lighter background and the red lining.
I will point out if you had red will have
green color blindness, this is not ideal,
but it does have some good contrast.
There's evidence of clear themes, specifically
within regions for a lot of these.
And a good example is the Japanese Mon.
One example, you can see that there's a blossom
and that symbolizes the renewal of life.
Often, they're recognizable even if someone
came from a different background.
In particular there's one with a sword, easy
to interpret.
An animal with bared teeth, that's pretty
understandable.
It's not a blanket rule, but in general they
have recognizable elements for people that
come from different backgrounds.
So, what are some things that could have been
done better in terms of modern standards of
accessibility?
This is an example.
Recognizable elements for people from different
backgrounds.
So, what are some things that could have been
done standpoint.
Could provide a description of what this looks
like.
But obviously it's intended to be a visual
thing.
You might think of the audible equivalent
as like a battle cry or something like that
as you're going into battle.
Or maybe a song.
Readability is not always great.
So, this is a coat of arms from Portugal that's
been printed ton some fabric.
It's beautiful look at, but it's hard it make
out the letters on the bottom there.
So, not superreadable.
Some of them are very complex.
Like this one from imperial Russia.
So, if I were to print this into a book and
able to look at all the details with a magnifying
glass, that would be interesting.
But on a coat of arms, a lot of this detail
would probably get lost.
Great.
Let's talk about what lessons we can take
away from some of these designs and some of
the problems they faced.
So, a big one is the meaning and unintended
meaning behind various symbols.
So, while I was researching this talk, I read
a paper from some students at Kansas State
University opt meaning of Chinese symbols
and what they mean in nonChinese cultures.
They gave a meaning of a fish, a symbol of
good luck and joy in China and is often used
in business logos as a result.
But if you were to apply this in a more western
context, a lot of times those are only used
in a logo geared towards children or a restaurant.
You could see where this could be confusing.
If I put a fish into my coat of arms and I
wanted to symbolize good luck and someone
from a western background saw it and thought
that my house was selling sushi.
Even symbols like animals that can seem clear
to us often have specific cultural connotations.
The international standard of organizations
provides some guidelines on symbols.
Stay away from hand gestures, religious symbols
and animals which can be ambiguous culturally.
You can use nature symbols in general like
sun or rain or flowers.
Graphics that are officially recognized by
the ISO and symbols that represent things
like equipment or transportation.
So, something like a truck or a hammer would
be pretty safe.
Abstract shapes like circles and squares are
also good choices.
I mentioned the international organization
of standards.
That's a body that was established by the
U.N. and is headquartered in Geneva.
Their purpose is to develop highquality standards
which facilitates exchange of goods, supports
growth, promote innovation and protect health,
safety and the environment.
So, you're probably familiar with some of
the icons that they've standardized.
They're things that are used in safety context
or on roads signs, at airports.
They can be things like hospital and no diving
sign.
And you can see by looking at these that they're
meant to be have a universal meaning.
You don't need to speak a particular language
to understand these.
I think another case study when it comes to
the meaning of symbols is interesting to look
at, the Mon from Japan.
I talked about earlier the blossom is the
symbol of the renewal of life.
If I came from somewhere else, I might be
able to guess that.
Plant life is frequently correlated with renewal
of life.
But it might be harder to understand not having
the right background.
There are others like this one in the top
right is four diamonds which might be unclear
to me at first glance.
So, some of these symbols are specific to
a particular region.
Another important lesson that we can take
away from heraldic design is the importance
of establishing a framework for your user.
As you probably know, we as human beings are
really good at recognizing patterns and dealing
with patterns.
And you see this in UI design or good UI design
with things like a menu which is pretty consistent
between websites.
That's very helpful to me if I need to go
to a website and find something that the navigation
is consistent.
And an example of this in heraldic design,
a lot of them had a very strict format for
a coat of arms.
So, this is a more western one and it shows
the helmet and two supporters and the battle
crier, a slogan across the stop.
If I studied these and I was very familiar
with their anatomy, I could read this and
look at a coat of arms and say, okay, the
supporters of this house are this and this
is the motto, and this is where everything
goes.
It's also good to remember that as sick as
you are of design, your users are not going
to be as sick of it.
This is called Jacob's Law of the Internet
User.
And basically, if you're looking at your own
website for maybe one hour or a couple hours
every single day, everyone your most active
users are only spending a couple of minutes.
So, in the course of a month you can imagine
that you would have maybe 30 hours of time
spent looking at your website whereas your
user would only have maybe 15 minutes or so.
And as a result, you might be sick of the
design and think that you need a refresh,
but your user doesn't have nearly the same
exposure to it.
So, it's a good thing to keep in mind in design
in general.
And heavily related, they've done Studies
that find that users actually like feeling
pretty exposed to a website.
So, you might think that they want a new and
edgy experience, but in reality, they probably
like feel like they know exactly how your
website works.
Another important lesson that we can learn
from heraldic design is the importance of
simplicity.
So, this is I think a good lesson from someone
named Steve Krug.
And he referred to users of the web as sharks
who have essentially going along and trying
to accomplish a specific thing.
And then they accomplish that and have to
keep going.
If they stop, they'll die.
They have to keep swimming.
If you can imagine your users when they go
to your website with not trying to stop and
smell the roses.
They're trying to accomplish one specific
thing.
And however, you can help them do that will
be good.
So, this is an example of where complexity
won out.
This is the 1915 code of arms for the AustriaHungarian
empire.
There's a lot going down here.
They got into the tradition of passing down
history in the coat of arms and there's a
bunch of flags and symbols jumbled together
here to the point that it's hard to get meaning
from looking at it.
It's obviously very interesting and if you
know what's going on, I'm sure it tells an
interesting story.
But might have been better to favor simplicity,
depending on your purpose.
Another important lesson that we can take
away is related to complex text flow.
So, maybe you've had this experience as an
engineer where you get your beige laid out
just right and everything looks awesome.
And then you add one word and all of a sudden
there's a line break.
And everything has been changed and it looks
horrible.
So, this is one of the examples of why text
flow is really hard to deal with.
In particular if you're changing the language
as well.
That's an added complication.
And in heraldic design there's a similar corollary.
I have to explain something first.
So, if I were a night going into battle, the
right side is the Dexter side and the left
side is the sinister side.
On a coat of arms, it looks like this, the
user's right side is their Dexter side and
the left side is the left is the feminine
and the right side is more masculine.
It ma tern signs go on the left.
They would put them together.
These are two coats of arms, one with Munich
and one from Frankfurt.
If I combine them, it looks like this.
You lose a lot of the original design.
Then we get this practice called impalement,
which is a form of heraldic combination or
marshaling of two coats of arms.
It's a little bit more nuanced.
This is an example of a composition of different
symbols that I think is more effective.
On the left you see the three blossoms here
which is representing one thing.
And then in the middle you have the two lions
which is another house.
And then on the right you have the bugles
and the crosses.
So, this is an example of how you could combine
several symbols in a more thought out approach
that ends up being more effective than just
kind of shopping them in the middle and sticking
them together.
And I think this is heavily correlated to
what it's like to deal with text sometimes.
There's not a clean way to chop it.
Often you have to think carefully about composing
elements.
And the bottom line it's hard, often it can
be like the diary page with text everywhere.
There's no one size fits all solution.
Specialization will be necessary in your approach.
To wrap up, if you take anything away from
this talk, try and favor simplicity over complexity.
It's a good idea to accomplish familiar frameworks
for your user.
And consider the meaning that your symbols
might have, particularly for people from a
different background.
So, if you take anything away, those are the
three things that I would hope that you remember.
And, again, I did Tweet out these slides.
Thank you for coming.
And I think we'll have some time for questions.
[ Applause ]